we turn now to new development to the
story we've been closely following here
concern over the chemicals used to
waterproof the turnout gear worn by
america's firefighters now the
international association of
firefighters has decided to break off
its relationships and reject any future
funding from any company using those
chemicals and offering full support for
a series of lawsuits filed on behalf of
firefighters claiming their cancers were
caused by those very chemicals
america's firefighters are responding to
a new kind of alarm that could put them
at risk
about a class of chemicals that's been
used for years to waterproof what's
known as their turnout gear
it's added to the turnout gear to keep
them dry
when a firefighter is actively using a
hose they get wet
if you are carrying 60 pounds of gear
already adding 40 extra pounds of water
weight when you get wet is a real um it
cuts down the uh
time that a firefighter can be active on
scene but professor graham peasley at
notre dame university who's been
studying the turnout gear used by fire
departments across the country says the
chemical used most widely until recently
known by its shorthand c8 presents its
own risk to firefighters
there's a strong correlation between the
c8 form of this chemical and two types
of cancer testicular cancer and kidney
cancer
it's the same class of chemicals in the
foam used by firefighters to put out
certain kinds of fires
it's all led to a series of lawsuits and
a warning now from the international
association of firefighters
and we're joined now by ed kelly who's
the president of the international
association of firefighters mr kelly
thank you so much for being with us
brian thank you and thank you for
shedding light on this very important
subject
you say it's no coincidence that there's
increased rates of cancer among
firefighters
well even going back to for decades
we've known that the exposures that we
endure when we respond to fires when
burning materials are off-gassing expose
us to carcinogens and lead to higher
rates of cancer what is a new revelation
is that our actual personal protective
equipment our bunker gear is actually
infused with carcinogens that we now
know we're re-exposing ourselves time
and time again so this is a new uh
threat that has emerged new reality uh
of how we're being exposed to these
carcinogens
you also say that the companies that
sell this gear with this chemical are
engaged in a public deception
what do you mean yeah we we would really
like to know
when these companies knew
that these carcinogens were exposing us
and what did they do about it
and i can tell you from our end we know
that they've com they've denied any
wrongdoing
so for your firefighter members this
must feel like a great betrayal to be
furnished this gear only to learn that
it's causing a potential cancer
in my opinion it's led to countless
deaths amongst firefighters at a young
age
and we are committed to taking this
fight on uh our members spoke loud and
clear at our convention we don't want to
be in bed with any chemical companies
and when it comes to you know these
chemical companies and what they've told
us
we're actively pursuing congressional
hearings to bring people before congress
to find out what they knew when they
knew it and what did they do about it
because our members deserve answers and
our families of our fallen deserve
answers
it was the case of a massachusetts
firefighter paul cotter that helped to
spur the research i was diagnosed with
prostate cancer
in
october of 2014.
i had
treatment
surgery early in 15 and uh
had to retire
from a job at any point when you were
serving as a fire lieutenant on the
force there did you have any kind of
warning that there was this potential
harm from the turnout gear the chemicals
used to coat it
no none at all
none at all
no one ever no one ever
thought about the gears
being dangerous
we wore it
shopping we wore it sitting around in
the kitchen
um you know it was our safety net
idea
it was only after cotter's cancer
diagnosis when his wife diane began to
do her own research and contacted the
notre dame professor that he learned of
the potential risk
i was pissed
and as a lot of firefighters
are in the same boat that i am
it led diane to become a champion in the
cause to investigate the use of the
chemicals in firefighters turn out gear
it changed everything brian when i tell
you it changed everything believe me
you don't want that cancer diagnosis
i get very emotional speaking about it
because he was a fireman's firefighter
so even now five years later it's
difficult to talk about this is a
epic
disaster as far as we're concerned we
call it the greatest deception ever no
direct link has been proven between the
chemicals used on the turnout gear and
any specific firefighters cancer
diagnosis but a growing number of
firefighters are demanding answers
meanwhile your members have to put on
that turnout gear every day they respond
to a fire
that's true
that's true and uh it's a um
it's a painful
uh reality of of the situation that
we're in so finally what's your message
to your firefighter members
that we're taking this fight head on and
we're not going to back down to anybody
and then we'll together we're going to
find a solution to this problem
all right ed kelly president of the
international association of
firefighters thank you so much for being
with us here this evening
brian thank you
the companies named in the lawsuit and
cited by the firefighters group have all
said they believed the chemicals were
safe when they used them and a number of
the companies say they no longer use the
chemicals in question
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media see if you agree with the
editors of mediaite and what they have
to say
you're watching brian ross investigates
the law and crime trial network